mouvement c'est des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé ni les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a girl a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum interne à
sion pour laisser les sahraouis le choix
de choisir le futur de choisir entre
l'indépendance et l'intégration maroc à
savoir que ce n'est pas une partie du
territoire marocain
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 7 juillet une
quatrième vague est elle inévitable le
variant delta du comité 19 continue
d'inquiéter désormais largement
majoritaire dans de nombreux
départements français notamment paris
qui dépasse le seuil d alerte avec 54
cas pour 100000 habitants
un conseil de défense il sera d'ailleurs
consacrée lundi prochain selon le porte
parole du gouvernement qui brandit la
menace d'un été gâchée les assassins du
président essien étaient des mercenaires
professionnels déclaration de
l'ambassadeur haïtien aux états unis
après le meurtre la nuit dernière du
président jouvenel mo is tué par un
commando dans sa résidence privée est un
siège a été décrétée en haïti une
réunion d'urgence aura lieu demain sur
le sujet au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
washington et londres évoque un acte
terrible et odieux bruxelles s'inquiète
d'une spirale de violence nouveau revers
pour julian assange et ses soutiens
wikileaks a en effet annoncé ce mercredi
que le gouvernement américain avait
obtenu de la justice britannique une
autorisation limitée pour contester la
décision du royaume uni de ne pas
extrader le lanceur d alerte vers les
états unis
pourtant en janvier dernier la haute
cour de londres est occupée pour la
santé mentale du journaliste avait
écarté toute extradition
[Musique]
donald trump lui ne lâche rien en plus
de six mois après avoir quitté la
fonction suprême le milliardaire annonce
attaquer en justice les géants du net
facebook google et twitter ainsi que
leurs patrons respectifs des poursuites
qui interviennent parce que six mois
jour pour jour après l'invasion du
capitole de washington par ses partisans
un événement inédit dans l'histoire
américaine sur lequel joe biden souhaite
que toute la lumière soit faite
[Musique]
le spectre d'une quatrième vague et la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants au
coeur des discussions entre eux olivier
véran et les représentants des corps
médical cet après midi le gouvernement
on se donne le corps médical se donne
jusqu'au conseil de défense de lundi
prochain pour présenter ou non de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
on retrouve sur place notre reporter
mona vous dès lors qu'ils se trouvent
donc avenue de ségur à paris bonsoir
mona depuis plusieurs jours le débat sur
une possible machination obligatoire
fait rage
il fait rage et un consensus a été
trouvé entre les différents ordres
médicaux et le ministre de la santé
olive et veyran puisque une charte a été
signée pour rendre le vaccin obligatoire
à tous elle les soignants cela reste
symbolique mais en tout cas un consensus
a été trouvé ici même au ministère de la
santé olivier veyrat a été fermé a
indiqué que la vaccination était une
chance elle est professionnelle à qui
nous avons parlé estiment qu'ils doivent
montrer l'exemple
sous peine de sanctions écouter les
large consensus s'est dégagé autour
d'une obligation vaccinale
bien sûr il faudra un délai pour aller
jusqu'à la loi nous espérons que cette
déclaration commune encouragera les
soignants et les personnels des ehpad
des secteurs sanitaires des secteurs de
l'aide à domicile à aller vers la
vaccination sur un vaccin obligatoire
quand il n'est pas respecté
l'employeur peut recourir au
licenciement ce qui me cause réelle et
sérieuse donc nous avons été jusqu'à
cette perspective
évidemment nous n'avons pas du tout
envie d'aller jusque là mais si la
vaccination obligatoire et mise en
oeuvre bien sûr il faudra en assumer
toutes les conséquences
aujourd'hui c'est le début d'un conte a
robot je pense que tous les ordres signé
aujourd'hui avec les employeurs les
fédérations pour dire aux professionnels
de santé quels qu'ils soient aux
accompagnants aussi où tous les
intervenants qui vont se présenter dans
des débats dans des établissements quel
que soit son niveau mais dure et qui va
être en contact avec un patient avec un
usager des souhaits avec le résident à
qu'il faut absolument se vacciner voilà
c'est un message fort envoyé à tous les
soignants même si cette charte n'est que
symbolique pour l'instant elle est
professionnelle à qui nous avons parlé
espère que cette obligation sera rendu à
tout est la population à cl taux de
vaccination ne commente pas parmi et les
soignants et bien il pourrait y avoir
une loi qui obligerait les plus
réticents à se faire vacciner puisque il
faut savoir que le taux de vaccination
est des soignants et de 57% dans les
ehpad et 64% dans les hôpitaux ce n'est
pas assez selon olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé et mona dans ce
débat quelle est la position de
l'opposition
et bien dès demain le premier ministre
jean castex reçoit lé chef de file du
parlement et des élus locaux
justement pour aborder ces questions et
tenter de trouver un consensus sur la
vaccination obligatoire pour le moment
vous l'avez compris le gouvernement
cherche des mécanismes d'incitation de
la vaccination à des français alors que
le variant delta et gagne du terrain
vraisemblablement en france le
gouvernement se donne jusqu'au conseil
de défense sanitaire prévue le lundi 12
juillet pour présenter ou non de
nouvelles restrictions et concernant la
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions ou encore l'extension du
pass et sanitaires des annonces sont
donc attendus lors de la prochaine
allocution du président de la république
la semaine prochaine merci mon âme ou
dès lors devant le ministère de la santé
à paris
et c'est dans ce contexte que la cnil
valide l'envoi aux médecins traitants
par l'assurance maladie de leur liste de
patients non vaccinés mais à certaines
conditions seulement le praticien devoir
détruire totalement cette liste dès la
fin de l'action de sensibilisation
gendarme des données justifie sa
décision par la situation sanitaire jeu
site exceptionnel et une chose est
certaine avec ce variant delta qui monte
on le disait la pression politique 1
continue de s'accentuer sur les
soignants globalement sur les français
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés le
débat a débuté en france on l'aura
compris même les syndicats se sont
prononcés cette semaine sur cette
question alors faut-il restreint les
libertés des non vaccinés y at il un
risque de divisions la société à la
rentrée c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
et avec nous pour en parler
pierre rochefort tellier infirmier à
l'hôpital beaujon à paris vous êtes
membre du collectif inter urgence
laurent alexandre essayiste et
chirurgiens enfin didier maïsto
journaliste indépendant bonsoir à tous
les toits messieurs merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france l'appel
aux français on est plus rester chez
vous qu'on a beaucoup entendu mais
vaccinez vous olivier verront donc ils
lancent un ultimatum aux retardataires
et réfractaires à la vaccination en
filigramme la menace que la vaccination
ne devienne obligatoire laurent
alexandre c'est cela qui nous pend au
nez
écoutez moi je suis plutôt optimiste on
observe que dans les sondages le
pourcentage de français qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner est passé de 41 % à
plus de 80 % entre janvier et juin
ça veut dire que chaque semaine y avait
5 % des français qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner en plus donc on a eu un
doublement des gens qui veulent être
vaccinés contre locaux vides de 19 ans
en six mois
je pense que ce taux va encore augmenter
notamment du fait que les vaccins arn
messager comme le modern and up there
qui sont majoritaires ont très largement
majoritaires ont extrêmement peu
d'effets secondaires
donc je pense que les craintes légitimes
qui ont eu les gens contre le hac sein
sont empreints de de s'effacer
progressivement et donc je pense qu'il
faut pousser les gens à se faire
vacciner mais je suis contre la
vaccination obligatoire contre
l'ensemble de la population en revanche
bien évidemment pour nous les soignants
pour l'ensemble des gens en contact avec
les malades la vaccination obligatoire
et nécessaire
le but des soignants c'est de sauver des
malades c'est de sauver des vies ça
n'est pas de les contaminer et de les
tuer quand ils sont fragiles
donc il est absolument indispensable de
de rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous les gens qui soigne il serait
criminel il serait totalement anti
déontologique anti éthique de toucher un
malade de soigner un malade sans être
vaccinés c'est inacceptable
pierre tellier qu'est ce que vous
répondez criminels antilles
déontologique de souche à un malade
quand on n'est pas vacciné votre réponse
alors tout d'abord le collectif
intervenants s'est absolument pas contre
le vaccin dont nous appelons bien
évidemment le plus largement possible à
se faire vacciner mais nous sommes
contre une obligation parce que nous
pensons qu'il faut mieux convaincre que
contraindre et que contraindre une
vaccination pour avoir des conséquences
très lourdes sur le sol et sur des
futurs plans de campagne de vaccination
on a des antécédents au niveau de
l'hôpital public au niveau des
personnels sur les vaccins de l'hépatite
b ça a été fait dans les années 70 on en
parle encore aujourd'hui 2 jusqu'en 2020
ou encore des recherches pour voir s'il
y avait des complications donc ça a
laissé des traces et je pense que forcer
les gens ça ne fait que renforcer les
craintes envers de la vaccination et ça
pourrait être préjudiciable pour
l'avenir et sur les futures campagnes de
vaccination notamment sur la grippe on a
tous les ans et je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle on a un travail qui est en
train d'être fait qu'ils évoluent les
les soignants sont quand même parler de
ceux qui sont les plus tenaces inné de
la population on a des chiffres qu'ils
veulent un peu rien dire puisque la thp
nous dit qu'on est vaccinée à 70% mais
n'a que les données sur ces sur des
profils qui sont vaccinées sur des sites
de l'ap hp est non absolument pas les
données des professionnels peuvent
signer à l'extérieur décide de l'ap-hp
on a d'autres données qui sont donnés
par les caisses primaires d'assurance
maladie qui donne à 91% parce qu'on met
directement sur une caisse différente de
la population classique et donc l'aller
les chiffres sont peut-être un petit peu
surélevé puisqu'il n'y a pas que des
soignants dedans mais on voit bien que
en tout cas on ne sait pas combien de
soignants ne sont pas vaccinés à l'heure
actuelle c'est un petit peu un écran de
fumée
puisqu'en réalité même si tous les
soignants sont vaccinés s'il doit y
avoir une quatrième vague il y aura une
quatrième vague
la réalité c'est qu'est ce que l'état
fait pour lutter contre cette pandémie
et l'état ne fait absolument rien
d'ailleurs de l'état comme consigne de
vivre avec cette épidémie est de ne pas
lutter contre ça si on voulait vraiment
lutter contre cette épidémie cette manne
cette pandémie
la première chose à faire sera était de
lever les bras les brevets contre sela
sur ses vaccins
la plupart des variantes nous observons
aujourd'hui viennent de pays qui n'ont
pas accès à des vaccins
donc tant qu'on laissera ces pays sans
vaccin on aura d'autres arbres qui
arriveront donc je je je suis un petit
peu aussi fatigué de cette
stigmatisation qui est fait sur des
soignants de la part notamment du
ministre de la santé qu'il ya 18 mois je
disais que les tests ne servent à rien
que les masques ne servent à rien
et que c'était une grippe c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué il vous
plonger votre recette accepter le fait
que nous sommes responsables et criminel
aujourd'hui nous sommes vecteur de la
pathologie quand l'état aujourd'hui le
gouvernement choisisse de continuer à
fermer des lits on peut tous être
vaccinés s il ya publie s'il ya plus de
soignant à l'hôpital il va pas pouvoir
faire grand chose et ne serait ce que
sur les pathologies autre que le coc
vide à l'heure actuelle l'hôpital sur
une urgence c'est de trouver des
soignants on en n'est pas vacciné les
soignants qu'il arrive on en est à
trouver des soignants ne serait ce que
pour faire fonctionner l'hôpital un
didier maïsto quand vous entendez pierre
un choc tellier dire voilà on en a marre
non soignants d'être stigmatisé l'état
ne fait finalement pas assez pour lutter
contre cette pandémie qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez vous êtes d'accord avec ce
ce diagnostic
oui je pense d'abord que la vaccination
est un acte individuel personnel
quasiment intime contraindre dans le
pays des lumières et de pasteurs puisque
c'est ce qu'on nous sert souvent les
gens à se vacciner c'est le pire moyen
d'arriver à une vaccination
premièrement deuxièmement les français
ne sont pas idiots
ce sont des gens qui disent qu'ils se
documente qui regarde toutes les études
et je parle pas des complotistes et
autres bizarreries qu'on peut trouver
parce que je sais que le débat souvent
se focalise pour déprécier un petit peu
les doutes fondamentaux qui sont mis en
avant comme l'a dit pierre schwab
effectivement c'était même le docteur
alexandre c'est bien légitime que les
gens doutent cette pandémie nous est
tombé dessus et les vaccins ont été très
vite fait on nous a dit 95 %
d'efficacité puis aujourd'hui on voit
bien que ce n'est pas le cas il ya
toujours un variant on est toujours en
retard d'un variant le principe d'un
virus c'est d'avoir des variants et donc
on sera toujours en retard d'un variant
troisième point puisque le docteur
alexandre en parler ce fameux sondage
cet enfant un sondage 81 % des gens des
citoyens français qui serait favorable à
la vaccination obligatoire se tendent à
ce sondage est un sondage au doxa pour
le figaro et france info qui est une
honteuse manipulation puisque c'est un
échantillon un panel de 1005 personnes
attendez je vous ai pas interrompu je
vais je vais je vais aller au bout on
nous entendîmes exemple mais ce que vous
voulez voilà donc 1005 personnes qui ont
été sélectionnés dans ce panel
en réalité j'invite tout le monde à le
regarder puisque le sondage est publique
il est sur le site de doxa 25%
simplement des français est très été
très favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire 33%
je cite les chiffres de mémoire mais je
ne pense pas me tromper été assez
favorable qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent et
oui assez peut-être oui assez favorable
et ce sondage en plus inclut les
personnes qui étaient déjà vaccinés pour
arriver au chiffre mirifique de 80% ça
ça s'appelle en fait de la manipulation
mentale c'est du nudge c'est du soft
power n'est ce pas en influence les gens
et on pense que ça vient d'eux et on a
en un style dans le débat public
cette finalement faculté d'adhérer à une
espèce d'intérêt général pourquoi les
gens se font vacciner aujourd'hui non
pas par un altruisme exacerbée je vais
être un peu cassant peut-être mais parce
qu'ils veulent partir en vacances
prendre des avions est allé au
restaurant c'est ça l'histoire du pain
sanitaires et pas sanitaire ce n'est pas
du tout des questions de santé publique
ce ne sont pas du tout les questions de
santé publique et moi je trouve ça assez
choquant parce que je vois que depuis
quatre ans les libertés individuelles et
collectives ce saut se réduisent comme
peau de chagrin
on va laisser la réponse à laurent
alexandre qui voulait réagir à lorient
n'était pas du tout du d'un sondage sur
les gens qui souhaitaient la vaccination
obligatoire je parlais du dd sondage
mensuel sur le pourcentage de français
qui souhaitent à titre personnel se
faire vacciner
donc je ne parlais pas du du sondage
doxa don mello parlait il faut bien voir
qu'en matière de vaccins c'est pas un
choix individuel si on à éradiquer la
variole qui est une menace beaucoup plus
grave que le coc vite c'est parce que la
vaccination contre la variole a été
généralisé était obligatoire dans tous
les pays du monde
donc la vaccination il ya une dimension
individuelle se protéger mais lieu
dimanche
on collective protéger les autres et
donc en réalité ce n'est pas uniquement
un acte individuel c'est aussi un acte
collectif
altruiste en me vaccine ans je protège
les autres et je le répète on est en
train d'éradiquer sur la surface de la
planète la poliomyélite comme on à
éradiquer la variole il ya 40 ans et ça
c'est hassan avait fait naître victoire
dans la plupart des pays du monde
un choix individuel ne permet pas
d'éradiquer une maladie par la
vaccination
avant de vous redonner la parole pierre
fabre intelligents devrait vous faire
écouter gabriel atteint qui est partie
évidemment les aussi en croisade en
faveur de la vaccination collective
écouter mais le vario n'attendra pas et
il nous faut dès aujourd'hui lui couper
l'herbe sous le pied et ne le vaccin je
le répète est la carte maîtresse pour
cela l'heure est à la mobilisation
générale à la vaccination massive
que ce soit en se faisant vacciner ou en
convainquant un proche de se faire
vacciner chacun détient une part de la
solution chacun peut prendre part à
l'épreuve d'immunité collective qui nous
attend cet été voilà débris natale
olivier vers en a rajouté une couche ce
soir ils font nous faut aller plus vite
dans la vaccination des adultes plus
loin
clairement pierres chaudes tellier on
sent une pression qui s'accentue
vous en tant que soignant on a compris
votre position vous êtes contre la
vaccination obligatoire mais ce que vous
allez vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce
côté on va s'atteler à convaincre les
réfractaires vous allez dans ce rôle là
vont par exemple notre c'est notre
mission c'est notre travail de
convaincre d'aller chercher à avoir le
consentement libre et éclairé
ça a toujours été la mission de les
protéger de songer en attendant après
deux collègues ils sont libres et
éclairés il est très clairement je vous
le dis sincèrement je ne connais très
clairement je pense que je dois avoir
moins de 20 de la main de collègues qui
sont pas vaccinés sur tous les collègues
que tu dois connaître et certainement
pas dans la plupart des collègues des
services d'urgence ou de réanimation
sont vaccinés à 100 % y est clairement
oui
vous vous sentez justement pas pardonné
mois à pierre achoppent tellier
c'est vrai que voilà j'écoutais un petit
peu les radios ce matin les débats on
sent une forme ça commence ce débat un
petit peu houleux entre les vacciner les
non-vaccinés presque une forme de
culpabilisation est ce que vous vous la
ressentez vous aussi à votre votre
niveau de ne pas en être le papa de vous
parce que je crois je crois savoir vous
êtes vacciné mais mais est-ce qu'il ya
sept ans on cherche à culpabiliser
maintenant ceux qui ne souhaitent pas se
faire vacciner est ce que la pression va
remplir et ces prochains temps selon
vous alors comme vous lie à l'hôpital à
l'heure actuelle notre pression elle est
surtout pour trouver du personnel
très clairement on n'en ai pas discuté
de la vaccination au sein de l'hôpital
d'urgence actuelle c'est d'essayer de
maintenir les lieux ouverts
si vous voulez à l'heure actuelle le
gouvernement a continué à affirmer 2008
100 lits nous avons sur la php là où
nous avions 400 lits de cerner sur la
psp en 2019 on en a 800 lits de terre
mais par manque de professionnels enfin
je veux dire on est dans une situation
déjà là à l'heure actuelle on n'a pas de
baco vide alors à calais à l'hôpital on
est déjà débordée au niveau des urgences
l'état ne ne garantit pas déjà les soins
de base
enfin je veux dire c'est non ça fait
trois ans qu'on se bat ça fait deux fils
2019 qu'on se bat pour avoir du matériel
du personnel et délits après une crise
comme ça on voit que l'état continue sa
politique de fermeture de livres
restrictions donc forcément qu'il va
falloir serrer les boulons pour sur le
personnel mais on s'en sortira
clairement pas et même si le kobe de
passe vers la crise hospitalière hell's
ass enceintes elles s'accentuaient
s'aggrave et en salle le gouvernement ne
répond absolument pas alors là que dit
il à un autre information de la journée
à la cnil qui a validé aujourd'hui
l'envoi au médecin traitant de la liste
de leurs patients non vaccinés par
l'assurance maladie ça veut dire quoi
clairement on va aller chercher les gens
un par un pour
les faire changer d'avis laurent
alexandre vous êtes d'accord avec cette
mesure
elle est nécessaire les médecins doivent
savoir lesquels de leurs patients sont
vaccinés ne sont pas vaccinés c'est une
nouveau du médecin qu'on a le plus de
prises notamment sur les personnes les
plus fragiles les personnes âgées qui
vont régulièrement voir leur médecin
généraliste notamment
et donc il est je trouve justifiée de
permettre aux médecins de voir parmi
leurs patients quels sont les très
fragile qui ne sont pas vaccinés
il ne faut pas oublier que chez les
personnes âgées on a un taux de
mortalité due qu'aux vite qui est
extrêmement sort chez les gens de plus
de 80 ans ces 180 fois plus élevé que
chez les gens plus jeunes et donc il est
normal que l'on permette aux au médecin
d'avoir un outil pour piloter la
vaccination des gens fragiles qui risque
d'avoir un accident grave voire de
mourir si la quatrième vague néo variant
delta se développe dans les semaines qui
viennent a dit d'aimer sur vous très
attaché toujours en liberté individuelle
ça vous a choqué justement que les cnil
valide cet envoi par l'assurance maladie
des non vacciné leurs médecins traitants
vont au contraire vont penser que ces
médecins qui sont proches des gens ont
vraiment un rôle à jouer
ça m'a choqué bien sûr mais ça m'a pas
surpris comme toutes les autorités
administratives indépendantes
la cnil n'est pas indépendante je
pensais que moins en france il y avait
encore le secret médical le docteur
alexandre vient d'un d'un trait de plume
anéantir à millet et est complètement
détruire le secret médical
deuxièmement je pensais que les peler
les praticiens qui ne peuvent pas
soigner aujourd'hui avait un rapport
direct de confiance avec leurs patients
quand vous avez un médecin surtout que
maintenant vous avez un médecin référent
moi j'ai un médecin référent comme tous
les français c'est pas un ami mais c'est
il connaît mon intimité
il connaît ma vie il connaît mes
pathologie il connaît mes habitudes et
ça m'appartient et juste
shihri tient à tanger sam yeh place ça
m'appartient et j'ai pas envie d'être
je n'ai pas envie stéphanie de mort ou
d'être dans un fichier dans les médecins
diront qu'ils le qu'il le détruiront
rien le le pea mais aujourd'hui rien ne
permet de l'affirmer
en plus on fait intervenir des du privé
avec l'assurance maladie avec les
pharmacies etc
ça sera un autre débat des officines qui
font office justement de récupération de
toutes ces données on ne sait pas ce que
deviennent ces données et moi ce que je
vois c'est que toute liberté perdu est
perdu et je fais confiance à mon médecin
de famille je fais confiance aux
rapports presque intime que j'ai avec
lui pour savoir ce que je dois faire ou
ne pas faire
et j'ai encore le droit d'avoir mon
libre arbitre et que les tous les
français que mon voisin que mon
pharmacien que mon épicier ou que mon
patron si j'en avais un ne soit pas au
courant de mon intimité demande dossier
médical ça c'est la base de toute
société démocratique et c'est la base de
toute société civilisée et évoluer et je
suis scandalisée oui que la cnil est
permis cette infamie normal et c'est une
messe et un propos gentiment
complotistes il n'a jamais été question
de donner ton cancérologique je
l'attendais a jamais été et j'ai une
liste je peux vous dire j'ai
cancérologie cas les lissiers on aime
bien châtie bien de monsieur alexandre
ya un petit s'il vous que le laisser
finir autistes non non non non non non
l'eugénisme gérard et génisses mais je
peux pas développer son nom mais c'est à
nous de dire oui c'est un propos oui
c'est un propos complotistes il est hors
de question pour les piégeant dossier
médical personnes marge et de ça c'est
être en paix reason liste a donc là tu
inventes on est au lit
rupture du dossier médical arrêté il n'y
aura que trois dans vos délires donc il
n'y aura pas de rupture du secret
médical
aucun acteur et miron sermonné savez
bien démentant pas là il faut arrêter
prétendre que l'épicier de maïs tu auras
son dossier médical parce que ça c'est
un mensonge complotistes voilà c'est un
mensonge complot tiff
ce n'est pas vrai que pour les piscines
orateurs de budget la liste de bien
diriger l'allemagne et ce genre de
facilités stupide
merci ce n'est pas complotistes en
france il y à douala
nous sommes le pays des droit de la
faire croire nous avons un conseil
constitutionnel la société transgène
manistes dont vous rêvez c'est un
mensonge monsieur alexandre dumas rester
dans leur délibéré à tous les moments tu
as menti
tu as menti monsieur alexandre tu
lamenter turballais milieu tranquille
avec ce débat on va on va rester sur
cette arête de vente il faut arrêter de
mentir
merci en tout cas bouvier maisto laurent
alexandre et pierre je peux que te dis
on va peu voilà merci d'avoir accepté ce
décryptage qui est devenu un vrai face à
face à heureusement que nous avions aux
pierres chaudes tellier au milieu pour
voilà pour pour ramener un petit peu de
paix sur ce plateau dont je taquine en
tout cas merci d'avoir accepté de ce
débat même si vous n'étiez pas d'accord
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
l'assassinât cette nuit du président
haïtien je venais le moïse par un
commando quel avenir pour le pays déjà
en proie à une grave crise économique et
puis nous parlerons de donald trump qui
poursuit en justice facebook twitter et
google six mois après les attaques du
capitole
[Musique]
oh
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chevaux ksari
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois d'en profiter en 2011 le monde
manque pas un petit peu non ah oui c'est
tous les fromages tous les soucis sont
toutes les les croissants la pâtisserie
traits de caractère des russes qui te
plaît l'amitié les gens les gens très
stylé fallu les français ne savent pas
je ne pensais jamais de ma vie faire la
courge on s'est mis
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes ne bouleverse
et nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à renault alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes même si
rennes c'est la même culture c'est la
même façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
à l'union
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution un
supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
prix puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement chinois en l'état actuel
des capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terres rares il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues avaient
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un peu
c'est il distingue la lumière il
distingue quoi exactement par le patient
et de lapins par exemple de reconnaître
les passages protégés dans la rue de
détecter des objets différents objets de
petite taille de grande taille plusieurs
niveaux en passe de les compter de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rtl
france si vous nous rejoignez haïti sous
le choc la nation la plus pauvre du
continent américain n'a plus de
président joël moïse a été assassiné par
un commando armé chez lui la nuit
dernière ce pays des caraïbes traverse
une grave crise politique et
d'insécurité depuis de nombreux mois
une situation qui nivelle et au
président accusé d'inaction d'être
confrontés à la défiance d'une grande
partie de ses concitoyens
françois xavier lambert c'est en direct
à la télévision que le premier ministre
par intérim d'haïti annonce la nouvelle
le président haïtien je vais neil moïse
a été assassiné chez lui dans la nuit
par un groupe d'étrangers parlant
espagnol et anglais
claude joseph annonce également que la
femme du chef d'état a été blessée se
trouve à l'hôpital dans un état grave
il appelle la population au calme et
assure que le maintien de l'ordre est
assuré même en tant que premier ministre
en exercice je peux garantir que la
continuité politique de l'état sera
assurée
l'assassinât du président haïtien
aggrave encore un peu plus le chaos dans
lequel s'enfonce haïti depuis plusieurs
années depuis son élection en 2016
joe vénale moïse n'a pas amélioré la
situation d'un pays gangréné par
l'insécurité est miné par la corruption
depuis un an les manifestations se
multipliaient contre le chef d'état
haïtien qui gouverner par décret et qui
avait outrepassé la fin de son mandat
prévu en février 2021
l'article 134 points 2 de la
constitution haïtienne dit que le mandat
du président est terminée eh bien nous
avons un président qui est en rébellion
avec la loi qui est là pour défendre la
loi la justice
nous avons clairement dit que nous
sommes sous la dictature le peuple nous
a demandé de prendre la décision de
descendre dans la rue avec le peuple de
dieu pour faire entendre sa voix auprès
de la communauté internationale
pour calmer la colère d'une population
impacté par les pénuries et une pauvreté
galopante
le dirigeant aura nommé sept premiers
ministres le dernier en date n'aura même
pas eu l'occasion de prendre ses
fonctions
je vais neil moïse n'aura également pas
pu mettre en place la vaste réforme
institutionnelle qui devait renforcer
les pouvoirs de l'exécutif après un vote
par référendum en vote repoussé pour
cause de crise sanitaire
face à cette situation de plus en plus
dégradées la communauté internationale
avait appelé à la tenue d'élections
législatives et présidentielle
transparente d'ici la fin de l'année
c'est donc une nouvelle période
d'instabilité et d'incertitude qui
s'ouvre pour le pays
en réaction la république dominicaine a
ordonné la fermeture immédiate de sa
frontière avec haïti et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jacques léon emile
président de l'association haïti
mémoires et cultures bonsoir valeo et
1000 en sous le choc après l'assassinât
de son président un pays sous le choc
comme mais bien entendu encore encore
une fois on va on va entendre
malheureusement les mêmes l'ancien à
savoir que à chaque événement dramatique
et bas une vanne est un espoir vain net
et on espère que c'est un cil des points
de départ d'un nouveau changement
et puis tu ne viens pas en tout cas la
première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que évidemment c'est cet
assassinat est un crime qui doit être
condamné sans réserve
cela dit joël moïse est victime de sa
propre politique et de 7 et de sa
manière de diriger le pays
quand un président dirige par décret et
en moins de cinq ans change cette fois
de premier ministre c'est qu'il ya un
problème de fond il a voulu se maintenir
mal depuis que les manifestations
il n'avait aucune maîtrise sur la
sécurité du pays sur les gangs qui
fonctionnait jusqu'à se damnent juste à
la semaine dernière on enregistre les
cas de quinze personnes ont été
assassinées
les gangs font régner leur pouvoir
support au coin c'est pratiquement sûr
tout le pays
voilà aujourd'hui jovenet joseph beuys
paye les choses il n'y a pas à s'en
réjouir comme bien entendu
alors pour moi ça sera soul est une
bonne question à qui profite le crime
à qui profite le crime et derrière cette
grande distance il y en a trois autres à
savoir qui est le commanditaire ou quels
sont les commanditaires de ces crimes
deuxièmement elles vont être les
conséquences on ne connaît pas
troisièmement est ce que la collectivité
internationale va continuer à fermer les
lieux
ouaddou a gardé une attitude
d'indifférence telle qu'elle l'a et
jusqu'à prise alors justement on va
essayer de prendre ces trois questions
dans le bon sens tout d'abord sur à qui
profite le crime
on a appris ce soir en tout cas par la
bouche de l'ambassadeur ici aux etats
unis qu il semblerait que les assassins
soient des mercenaires professionnels
on imagine qu'elle beaucoup de mobiles
puisque beaucoup de monde ne les met pas
en haïti mais est ce qu'on peut avoir
une idée peut-être plus précise les
observateurs aguerris d'haïti ont une
idée peut-être plus précise de
l'identité de ce commando où on est dans
le flou absolu ça peut être finalement
n'importe qui on en est au stade des
conditions le fait le fait que ce soit
des mercenaires ça me paraît tout à fait
libre dans la mesure où ça s'est déjà
produit en haïti et en 1958
un groupe d'officiers haïtiens s'étaient
rebellés contre duvalier devenant de
miami il était arrivé avec des
mercenaires donc l'assaut s'est déjà
produite
donc c'est possible at il été assassiné
est le de la question est ce ce n'est
pas forcément partie mais qu'elle aime
quels sont les commanditaires mais c'est
un commando qui agit à peu qu'elle
appliquait les séries mairie pour le fer
en finale sur les réactions lui se dit
choquée préoccupée par le risque d'une
spirale de la violence baizen joe biden
américain réagit lui aussi il ya une
réunion au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui est prévue demain le monde semble
découvrir les problèmes d'haïti
ce soir on comme si on envoyait ou la
première en automne et la première fois
ça fait des mois que c'est à dire et la
stabilité que l'insécurité dieu en haïti
on le sait je savais qu au moins depuis
le début de l'année pour le stress alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait tu as su je suis
très sévère avec la communauté
internationale bien entendu avec les
haïtiens au site
parce que les hommes politiques à issia
ils n'ont fait qu'un pistolet qui
corrompent n'est pas sûr tout ne pas
vouloir s'entendre
j'ai une question simple les gars tout
petit mon fils à l'aise
la semaine dernière a été utile serait
mise à nommer un nouveau premier
ministre
le premier ministre actuellement en
place qui a annoncé ce n'est pas mal à
l'image du président et se dit les
affaires courantes alors exclusive à
continuer ou le premier ministre qui a
été nommé qui va prendre les rênes du
pouvoir
moi j'ai quatre positions à prendre sur
la question mais voilà cette nuit je
vois là une fille à battre
hilton de discorde déjà dans les milieux
politiques haïtiens l'insécurité on sait
gré d'un le pays
désormais cet assassinat cette absence
se plongent le pays haïti
dans encore plus d'inconnues si c'est
possible même tellement maintenant qui
va succéder qui va succéder de banias et
dans quelles conditions les élections
vont devoir avoir lieu mais que va-t-il
se passer qui va être élu je vous
rappelle quand même bien génial moïse a
été évité une base électorale que disait
deuxième participation de 10% de
l'électorat et que je faisais louis
n'est pas le cas qu'il est n'est pas
tout blanc dans la sphère une fois plus
soit parce que il était quand même
soupçonné de corruption dans la sphère
petro caribe au coeur voyez encore une
fois j'aime bien je veux pas que la
compagnie avait passé mais je ne les ai
pas du tout bleu membre cet homme ce
n'est pas au moment de manifestations de
800 n'a tout simplement ils ne sont pas
non plus c'est agréable
merci en tout cas jacques ayant émis le
président de l'association ecti mémoires
et cultures d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce soir
julian assange le journaliste emprisonné
à londres pourrait-il à nouveau être
sous la menace d'une extradition aux
etats-unis le fondateur de wikileaks qui
a passé le 3 juillet dernier son 50e
anniversaire en prison
pour plus de précisions retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter thomas bonnet en
direct de washington bonsoir thomas
pourquoi julian assange aurait-il sous
la menace d'une extradition soudainement
et bien parce que la justice britannique
a autorisé washington à faire appel de
sa décision en date du 4 janvier dernier
on rappelle que la justice britannique
s'était prononcé contre l'extradition de
julian assange en invoquant notamment
les problèmes de santé de du journaliste
lanceurs d'alerté alors l'appel a été
acceptée mais il serait selon les
entourages et selon les informations de
wikileaks limiter à des aspects
techniques
on a pour le moment pas tellement de
détails sur la procédure
sur une éventuelle date pour une
audience écoutez la réaction du
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks
cette décision intervient seulement une
semaine après qu'il a été révélé que
l'acte d'accusation contre julian était
sans fondement le témoin clé a rétracté
son témoignage est dit que le témoignage
qui a été reconnue par le juge
britannique qui à plusieurs reprises
repose sur une allégation véridique qui
n'est pas entièrement vrai c'est une
machination
les américains le savent mais reste
campé sur leurs positions
cet appel est une tentative désespérée
de retarder l'inévitable l'inévitable et
la libération de julian assange
s'il n'obtient pas sa liberté
ce sera un coup énorme porté à notre
société mais c'est comme si on le passé
sous silence
cela doit donc se terminer que je sens
qu au fond de moi cela arrivera bientôt
un thomas quelle conséquence à cette
décision sur son avenir alors vous avez
entendu l'optimisme du rédacteur en chef
de wikileaks mais force est de constater
que je les récents jeux va rester en
prison dans cette prison de haute
sécurité de belmarsh au royaume uni au
moins jusqu'à cette nouvelle audience a
priori sauf évolution dans cette affaire
cette prison de haute sécurité où les
conditions de détention sont
intolérables ce sont les mots de
l'épousé de l'accompagner pardon de
julian assange d'ailleurs sa compagne a
réagit également à cette décision de la
justice britannique
je repose là encore de l'écouter si
l'administration buydens bas tient
vraiment à respecter l'état de droit
le premier amendement et la liberté de
la presse dans le monde la seule chose
qu'elle puisse faire est d'abandonner
cette affaire cette affaire et leurs
tacles à +10 yeuse de l'histoire
alors vous avez entendu la compagne de
julian assange en appel à la nouvelle
administration byden il y avait eu
quelques espoirs assez mince finalement
lorsque joe biden est arrivé au pouvoir
avec beaucoup d'appels pense par exemple
à l'appel de genève pour justement
encourager la nouvelle administration de
la maison blanche a abandonné les
poursuites contre julian assange
mais il faut dire qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement de changement en témoigne
également le lan et l'interview dont
tony blinken le secrétaire d'état
américain qui était en france il
interviewait par nos confrères de brut
justement sur le sort de julian assange
il avait plutôt botté en touche on sent
que il ya un peu de c'est un peu
compliqué de répondre pour la justice
pour les autorités américaines mais qui
compte véritablement continuer à
demander l'extradition de julian assange
on rappelle que les charges contre le
lanceur d'alert sont sous le coude dans
le cadre de l'espionage act et qu'il
encoure si toutes les charges sont
retenues contre lui jusqu'à 175 ans
d'emprisonnement ici aux etats unis
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington est toujours aux etats-unis
six mois après joe biden revient sur les
événements violents du capitole dans un
communiqué le président américain
appelle le congrès à enquêter avec
courage sur cette violente attaque il y
en a également profité pour faire un
état des lieux de la démocratie
américaine
selon lui l aurais je suis survécu mais
se doit de rester protégé et préservé
afin d'assurer la pérennité aux états
unis
il y a 6 mois des insurgés ont mené une
attaque violente et meurtrière au
capitole il s'agissait d'un test afin de
savoir si notre démocratie survivrait un
an et demi après cet événement nous
pouvons affirmer que la démocratie est
toujours debout
maintenant il ne dépend que de nous de
la protéger et la préserver et de son
côté donald trump annonce des poursuites
contre facebook twitter google et leur
patron depuis l'assaut du capitole ex
président américain avait été évincée
des grands réseaux sociaux empêchent ans
l'intéressé a annoncé qu'il lançait une
plainte collective contre ses gaffes en
les accusant d'être responsable je suis
d'une censure illégale et
inconstitutionnelle en juin après
twitter c'est facebook qui avait
suspendu donald trump pour deux ans
l'ex-président comptait plus de 100
millions d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis atlanta avec chad ouigours
journaliste politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir chadwick mans merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donald
trump qui passe donc à l'attaqué
incontrôlée géant du net et leur patron
ils s'attaquent à plus puissant que lui
une fois n'est pas coutume a déjà
attaqué les gens plus puissant et s'est
déjà attaqué à la bit tech mais il
s'agit ici d'une plainte qui ne pourra
pas aboutir
les gens ont déjà essayé dans le passé
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'il semble s'agir d'une stratégie
[Musique]
il sera intéressant de voir comment la
biotech se défendra ils devront dire
qu'ils sont un éditeur et qui a le droit
d'empêcher certaines voix de s'exprimer
sur ces plateformes
extec a déjà défendu cette théorie dans
plusieurs tribunaux
il dit cela dans les tribunaux civils
mais lorsqu'il se retrouve devant le
congrès ils disaient qu'ils ne sont pas
des rédacteurs qu'ils sont des
plateformes neutre c'est important car
la section 230 du communication spéciale
ces actes permet à ces grandes
entreprises de survivre car à cette
section la donne des privilèges spéciaux
ne peuvent pas être traduit en justice
pour le contenu qu'il ya sur leur site
car ils ne sont pas des rédacteurs comme
par exemple le new york times mais des
plateformes neutre on qu'il dise à un
certain niveau qu'ils sont des éditeurs
et un autre niveau qu'il s'agit de pas
forme neutre alors cela commence à
construire la base
la destruction interne de cette section
230 ce qui serait une grande victoire
pour les gens qui veulent s'attaquer à
la big tech donc cette plainte est sans
doute stratégique car il s'agit de
pousser ces entreprises à admettre
devant les tribunaux qui ne ce ne sont
pas des plateformes neutre mais qu'ils
ont un pouvoir de tri et qu'il devrait
donc être considérée non pas comme des
plateformes neutre mais comme des
éditeurs des des rédacteurs ils le sont
bien que les tribunaux n'ont pas encore
reconnu
en tout cas les avocats de donald trump
pour une stratégie à comme vous dites
ils l'accusent tout simplement ces
plateformes d'être responsable d'une
censure illégal inconstitutionnelle
esquissé pendant cette qualification
juridique est ce qu elles ont quand même
des chances d'aboutir selon vous c'est
difficile à dire personnellement je
pense que la plainte n'aboutira pas mais
ce n'est pas l'objectif
l'objectif est que ces entreprises
admettent devant les tribunaux ce
qu'elles font réellement ce qu'elles
sont réellement juge fédéral en floride
a décidé de d'infliger une amende à
l'habitacle mais le juge au niveau
fédéral a refusé cette amende disant que
cela allait à l'encontre du droit à la
libre expression
s'il s'en libère une tendance à
identifier correctement au niveau légal
ces plateformes comme des éditeurs et
non pas des plateformes complètement
notre plateforme prétendent qu'elles ne
sont pas responsable de ses contenus
du moment qu'il ne trie pas les contenus
mais malheureusement vérité en face et
il met en place une censure ils trient
les contenus et ne respecte donc pas la
règle de l'expression libre
il sauve son milieu complet il faut
savoir que ces entreprises ça c'est le
nouveau forum de discussion c'est la
place publique
l'état californien a établi que des
passez la propriété de public lorsque le
public qui a un accès raisonnable doit
se conformer à la protection de
l'expression publique
cela a été défini par exemple dans les
centres commerciaux
et cela pourrait s'appliquer ici donc on
dirait bien que tout cela va vers une
affaire devant la cour suprême sur la
liberté d'expression et ses entreprises
de la bit tech qui contrôle le discours
public qui ont contrôlé qui peut parler
en politique est acquis et partiaux et
qui prétend que cependant être
parfaitement notre ce qui est bien sûr
un mensonge alors certainement que
donald trump poursuit peut-être une
autre stratégie celle de faire parler de
lui à nouveau puisqu'on lui a coupé le
sifflet un si j'ose dire sur toutes ces
grandes plateformes
est ce que cette possibilité justement
qu'il fédère encore un peu plus ses
partisans contre justement l'attitude
des gaffes a déjà contre les gaffes à
car ce sont eux qui sont ciblés des
milliers des centaines de milliers de
personnes
ses soutiens les plus importants les
plus brillants ont été les premiers à
être panier qu'à résister très efficace
dans la transmission du message de à
donald trump de ne pas voter pour les
démocrates
effectivement donald trump eux aiment
avoir un canal pour s'exprimer il a plus
le droit de s'exprimer sur twitter et il
faut savoir que ces entreprises perturbe
beaucoup d'argent car beaucoup de gens
étaient sur ces plateformes pour donald
trump
mais ses soutiens toujours été la cible
de ces compagnies de ces entreprises et
n'ont aucune confiance en ses
entreprises
même si beaucoup
d'entreprise même si beaucoup de
plateformes alternatives sont apparus et
pourtant ils sont toujours coincés dans
ces entreprises comme une forme de
monopole qui opèrent en coulisses et par
exemple si l'on parle de l'app store et
bien il ya de la corruption et du trafic
d'influencé a pu hier ses entreprises
pour ce qu'elles font c'est pour ce
qu'elles font à la politique sera un
processus très long et cela commence ici
en réussissant à faire admettre à ses
entreprises ce qu'elles sont exactement
et qu'elle ne respecte pas le droit
américain que cette section de 130 leur
donne trop de puissance alors censure de
noël trump entre guillemets depuis la
sphère du du capitole le ski janvier à
ce propos de joe biden qui appelle
aujourd'hui le congrès a enquêté avec
courage ça veut dire quoi concrètement
enquêter avec courage est ce que le
pendant c est ce que cela peut nuire à
donald trump clairement historiquement
cet amour étrange et cela semble presque
dystopique c'est comme si on me
demandait courageusement au congrès de
violer leur engagement envers le peuple
américain de mener une enquête sur des
citoyens comme si c'étaient des
terroristes
simplement parce que
le gouvernement n'a pas aimé la façon
dont ils ont voté cette affaire du 6
janvier a été développé bien trop hors
de proportion il n'y avait qu'une
quelques centaines de personnes le
capitole n'étaient pas gardés du tout il
y avait que quelques officiers de police
et certaines personnes ont marché dans
les couloirs n'ont rien cassé ont pris
quelques selphy un podium a été volé
c'est tout une personne a été tuée
c'était une soutien de total qui a été
tué par un policier de capital
voilà tout ce qui est arrivé le 6
janvier pourtant les méta les démocrates
construisent de toutes pièces une
rhétorique l'histoire selon laquelle les
états unis ont été pris d'assaut par des
sucres et mme insiste blanc
mais ces gens là il y en a très peu et
il ne se montre pas en public la plupart
la majorité des soutiens de donald trump
sont des gens pacifiques et ce ne sont
pas ces gens qui ont incendié qui ont
plié dans toutes nos villes l été
dernier
et pourtant nous nous voilà c'est
vraiment de la manipulation
l'administration de biden a déclaré que
la plus importante menace terroriste aux
etats unis ce sont les nationalistes
gland personne ne sait ce que c'est et
personne ne peut indiquer ne serait ce
qu'une seule personne mu en voici un
nationaliste blanc car il n'y a rien de
tel au niveau national c'est vraiment
terrible pour ce pays le gouvernement
fédéral cible des électeurs qu'ils
n'aiment pas et essaie d'intimider et
apeuré le peuple américain afin qu'un
candidat surprise comme donald trump
depuis jamais réapparaître
merci schalwyk moore journaliste
politique un programme part évidemment
on l'aura compris à ces propos qui
n'engagent que vous que vous nous avez
en tout cas apporter votre analyse
puisque toutes les voies sont entendus
sur rt france rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du port
du masque en extérieur faut-il le rendre
à nouveau obligatoire comme le font
certaines villes pour l'été
avec la propagation du variant delta
plus et puis on fera le point sur la
situation du coc vide en espagne où le
taux d'incidence a été multiplié par 8
ces quinze derniers jours
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative au
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
une république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté je
vous remercie d'avoir invité
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers ont été compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rex it
le vrai sujet c'est celui de faire
dialoguer les douaniers français les
poignées britannique est ce qui
m'inquiète dans le bric site c'est pas
le break 6 et la bureaucratie du brics
comment ça va se passer par exemple pour
l'été qui arrive la côte d'azur verra
peu ou pas d'anglais je suspecte
effectivement le gouvernement
britannique d'essayer de convaincre les
britanniques de rester en grande
bretagne pour faciliter la relance de
l'économie britannique par rapport à la
crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
[Musique]
merci on a identifié un peu plus de 500
depuis un an et demi les alertes
concernant les menaces de prédation sur
des entreprises françaises se
multiplieront vous avez un pays qui est
affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
ça intéresse les prédateurs parce qu'ils
savent que vous ne pourrez pas vous
défendre
ça peut le chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous actuellement dans cette guerre
économique il ya le darwinisme classique
et économiques et les gros mangent les
petits mais là on se trouve devant un
nouveau type de risque le droit est
maintenant utilisée par les états pour
aider leurs entreprises notamment à
affaiblir d'autres entreprises
étrangères
tous les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'économie ne savent pas ce
que c'est qu'une entreprise qui s'ils
ont jamais mis les pieds donc ne leur
demandez pas défendre quelque chose qui
ne connaissent pas vu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie de
taxis en france l'activité a reprise
d'apaisement dans paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de tourisme
étranger les chauffeurs sont un peu à la
peine garé ya 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrente des vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a on a doublé les
20000 à 45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque paysage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 7 juillet une quatrième
vague est elle inévitable le variant
delta du coc vite 19 continue
d'inquiéter désormais largement
majoritaire dans de nombreux
départements notamment paris qui dépasse
le seuil d alerte avec 54 cas pour
100000 habitants
un conseil de défense il sera d'ailleurs
consacrée lundi prochain selon le porte
parole du gouvernement qui brandit la
menace d'un été gâchée répondait me qui
a fait plus de 4 millions de morts dans
le monde le secrétaire général de l' oms
qui pointe aussi le risque d'agir comme
si la pandémie était passé l'espagne
notamment la catalane fait face à une
flambée de cas positifs en raison de la
propagation du vaillant belta ce dernier
inquiète aussi en argentine le pays se
rapproche de triste cap des cent mille
morts
les essais nucléaires au sahara le
ministre algérien des moudjahidine
dénonce le refus français de l'accès aux
cartes des déchets toxiques des tirs
nucléaires dans le désert algérien
dix sept essais
ont eu lieu entre 1960 et 1966 tayeb
zitouni déplore qu'il n'y a eu aucune
initiative en vue de dépolluer les sites
ni aucun acte humanitaire en vue le
dédommager les victimes
[Musique]
le spectre d'une quatrième vague et la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants au
coeur des discussions entre olivier
ferrand et les représentants du corps
médical cet après midi le gouvernement
se donne lui jusqu'au conseil de défense
de lundi prochain pour présenter ou non
de nouvelles mesures restrictives ont
fait le point avec notre reporter
monnaie à bout dès lors un consensus a
été trouvé à l'unanimité entre le corps
médical et le ministre de la santé olive
et veyran puisque une déclaration
symbolique a été signé pour rendre
obligatoire la vaccination auprès des
soignants
olivier ferrand a été fermé a indiqué
que la vaccination est peut-être une
chance
les professionnels de santé à qui nous
avons pu parler estime qu'ils doivent
donner l'exemple sous peine de sanctions
écouter les un large consensus s'est
dégagé autour d'une obligation vaccinale
bien sûr il faudra un délai pour aller
jusqu'à la loi nous espérons que cette
déclaration commune encouragera les
soignants et les personnels de des ehpad
des secteurs sanitaires des secteurs de
l'aide à domicile à aller vers la
vaccination sur un vaccin obligatoire
quand il n'est pas respecté
l'employeur peut recourir au
licenciement ce qui nous cause réelle et
sérieuse donc nous avons été jusqu'à
cette perspective
évidemment nous n'avons pas du tout
envie d'aller jusque là mais si la
vaccination obligatoire et mise en
oeuvre bien sûr il faudra en assumer
toutes les conséquences
aujourd'hui c'est le début d'un conte a
robot jeu presque tous les ordres signé
aujourd'hui avec les employeurs les
fédérations pour dire aux professionnels
de santé quels qu'ils soient aux
accompagnants aussi où tous les
intervenants qui veut se présenter dans
des débats dans des établissements quel
que soit son niveau mais dure et qui va
être en contact avec un patient avec un
usager des souhaits avec un résident
qu'il faut absolument se vacciner est
les professionnels de santé espère que
cette obligation sera rendu à toute la
population ainsi de taux de vaccination
n'augmente pas d'ici la rentrée du côté
des soignants une loi pourrait être
votée pour obliger les plus réticents il
faut savoir que le taux de vaccination à
des soignants et de 57% dans les ehpad
et de 60 4% dans les hôpitaux mais ce
n'est pas assez
selon olivier ferrand et dès demain jean
castex recevra les chefs de file du
parlement et des élus locaux notamment
pour aborder et les questions de la
vaccination obligatoire pour le moment
le gouvernement réfléchit à des
mécanismes d'incitation à la vaccination
des français alors que le variant delta
gagne du terrain
le gouvernement se donne jusqu'au
conseil de défense sanitaire qui aura
lieu le lundi 12 juillet pourra
présenter ou non de nouvelles
restrictions concernant est la
vaccination obligatoire pour certains
corps de métiers ou encore l'extension
du pass sanitaire des annonces sont donc
attendus lors de l'allocution du
président de la république et la semaine
prochaine alors sous la menace du
variant delta fait-il rien imposer le
port du masque certaines villes comme le
tout et l'on depuis quelques jours
rendue obligatoire dans certains espaces
une mesure mise en place pour tout l'été
mais est-elle soutenue par tous pour en
parler nous sommes avec eric bérive
merdes génération terrain de la roche la
molière dans département de la loire
bonsoir ami qui avait avivé merci d'être
avec nous l'initiative du maire du
touquet est ce qu'elle doit se
généraliser pour éviter une quatrième
vague selon vous alors bon sur un tour
se généralise et peut-être pas mais
adapter à différentes situations
quand on est dans une ville touristique
avec un afflux de personnes
évidemment il faut adapter la situation
avec le respect des gestes-barrières et
pourquoi pas en rajouter l'obligation du
port du masque quand ya une forte
densité on sait que le civisme n'est
tout pas toujours au rendez vous il faut
vraiment adapté à chaque situation pour
chaque endroit de généraliser je pense
que c'est pas nécessaire mais d'adapter
en fonction des situations oui je pense
que c'est nécessaire par contre ça veut
dire quoi qu'on va porter le masque à
nouveau dans la rue mais qu'on va
continuer d'aller dans des restaurants
ou de faire du sport dans des salles de
sport plutôt confiné
alors effectivement il faut revivre
normalement parce que c'est difficile
mais on sait très bien que quand on est
sûr
une ville très touristique quand on est
dans une rue commerçante collés les uns
aux autres il peut y avoir un risque de
diffusion de ce nouveau variant et c'est
là où c'est nécessaire justement de
d'essayer de respecter des règles
collectives et d'ainsi règle collective
via le lavage des mains à la
distanciation sociale mais elle est
difficile à certains endroits et donc
s'il est difficile bien le port du
masque est incontournable et nécessaire
quatre positions défendez vous dans
votre propre aux communes alors dans ma
commune
tout ce qui est bâtiments municipaux à
l'intérieur des bâtiments municipaux
on regarde le masque évidemment mes
dents sur la voie publique on n'est pas
une ville touristique donc on regarde la
distanciation se fait facilement donc le
masque n'est pas obligatoire et je ne
l'obligerait pas et puisque nous avons
la surface nécessaire et quand on a des
événements en extérieur par exemple ce
samedi on ne fait pas le bal
traditionnel de début d'été ce qu'on
appelle le bal du 14 juillet la fête de
l'été on va le faire différemment on va
le diffuser sur la radio locale et les
genres seront la fête de chez eux donc
on s'est quand même un bal mais un peu
confiné pour éviter les grands
rassemblements et ce sont des
rassemblements familiaux ou de voisinage
qui seront pour qu'on puisse quand même
vous faire une fête populaire
c'est la transition avec le retour à la
normalité hors pandémie
vous trouvez qu'on a tourné peut-être la
page trop vite on est passé de cette
époque que vous nous rappeler on faisait
peut-être la fête à la maison en
entendant soit des concerts classiques
soit des dj soit des balles peu importe
selon les goûts ah voilà le tout liberté
avec d'ailleurs l'ouverture prochaine
des des discothèques on va trop vite
selon vous je pense que les autorités
sanitaires prennent les dispositions
qu'il faut mais il faut pas que la vie
s'arrête donc il faut trouver des
solutions alternatives et progressive
je pense qu'il faut qu'on est du cas par
cas et en responsabilité
c'est quand même important de retrouver
une vie normale où les gens puissent
échanger discuter passer des moments
ensemble
mais il faut pas oublier qu'à ces
pandémies donc évidemment
se faire vacciner c'est indispensable
pour la plupart d'entre nous et en un
accès on a la chance d'en france d'avoir
l'accès gratuit à la vaccination aux
tests etc
c'est pas le cas de tous les pays du
monde donc il faut utiliser ces outils
là pour justement retrouver une vie
normale encore plus rapidement si on a
une vaccination généralisée
on va justement atténuer cette pandémie
et donc c'est une chance pour nous de
pouvoir le faire alors le letton deux en
réanimation n'ont jamais été aussi bas
depuis très longtemps
ça veut dire quand même que le vaccin il
faudrait c'est la piste en tout cas
qu'ils aimeraient bien prendre le
gouvernement mais qui n'osent pas les
jeux jusqu'au bout pour l'instant il
faudrait la rendre obligatoire cette
vaccination pour éviter justement les
formes graves de coville est ce que
c'est votre avis où on doit rester libre
et et tâcher de convaincre les
récalcitrants pour les autorités en tout
cas on est on est un pays de liberté
donc la liberté de faire nous de ne pas
faire je pense qu'il faut garder cette
liberté néanmoins il faut fortement
conseillé expliqué ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner que
c'est indispensable si on veut retrouver
une vie tous ensemble une vie normale
donc il faut vraiment se faire vacciner
et ceux qui ne souhaitent pas je dirais
tant pis pour eux malheureusement mais
on a cette chance d'avoir un système de
santé extraordinaire en france où il ya
une prise en charge ou les collectivités
comme chez nous notre métropole a mis en
place un vaccinodromes wall un accès
très facile tràs aisée pour se faire
vacciner et je vous garantis que moi qui
serait temps qu'ils aient peur des
aiguilles
j'ai rien senti j'aimais mes deux doses
de qui ont été le fait et je me porte
très bien et je pense que tout le monde
devrait aller dans cette direction là
donc faites vous vacciner
donc on retrouve une vie saine normale
et agréable et évidemment les variants
vont arriver certains sont porteurs
mais il faut penser surtout aux autres
pour garder ses gestes barrières
certaines personnes qui sont en très
bonne santé
évidemment nous avons pas besoin mais il
faut penser à tout le monde mais il faut
avoir cette solidarité et cette empathie
et cette sincérité envers les autres
donc faites vous vacciner c'est l'essai
des solutions pour sortir de tout ça
merci en tout cas avec l'arrivée merde
génération terrain de la roche la
molière dans le département de la loire
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et l'espagne est présent
notamment la catalogne qui fait face à
une flambée des cas positifs en raison
de la propagation du bail en delta le
point sur la situation avec notre
correspondante à barcelone clémentine
lors ce n'est plus une vague c'est un
déferlement de kobe de 19 en catalogne
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
groupe d'experts qui travaille avec le
gouvernement catalan car ici en espagne
la situation sanitaire s'est fortement
dégradée en seulement quelques jours
alors qu'on pensait pouvoir vivre un été
presque normal c'est en tout cas le cas
dans plusieurs régions mais c'est en
catalogne où les chiffres sont les plus
alarmants les contaminations repartent à
la hausse après une longue période
stationnaire et aujourd'hui une personne
malade en catalogne en contamine plus de
3 ce qui est énorme et pour 40% des cas
il s'agit du variant delta 1 pariant qui
prend de plus en plus de place ici et de
plus selon les experts ce chiffre
pourrait monter à plus de 60% dans les
prochains jours alors en conséquence
même si ce sont surtout des jeunes qui
tombent malades ici en catalogne les
centres sanitaires sont saturés et le
personnel soignant est à bout de souffle
on a presque l'impression de revivre la
même situation que l'année dernière
alors qu'en pensent les barcelonais
cette situation était-elle prévisible
nous leur avons posé la question je
pense que les gens avaient très envie de
sortir de chez eux et d'avoir des
relations sociales alors maintenant que
c'est beaucoup plus facile de le faire
les gens sont sortis et ont fait ce
qu'ils étaient à prévoir
je pense que les gens ne prennent pas
les mesures aussi sérieusement qu'ils le
devraient
donc moi je m'attendais à ce qu'on fasse
marche arrière
la situation est très mauvaise car les
jeunes ne sont pas conscients de la
gravité de la situation au niveau
mondial alors leur compte
ça augmente et je pense qu'il faudrait
prendre plus de mesures alors face à
cette remontée des contaminations
le gouvernement catalan après une
décision ferme et les discothèques
seulement deux semaines après leur
réouverture pour le secteur du monde de
la nuit c'est une décision radicale qui
passe très mal car la discothèque avait
très mal vécu la fermeture durant la
pandémie
effectivement c'était d'ailleurs les
derniers établissements à ouvrir il ya
deux semaines et il avait dû appliquer
un protocole sanitaire extrêmement
strictes alors aujourd'hui les
professionnels du secteur se sent
totalement lésés par le gouvernement
parce qu'ils doivent remettre au chômage
partiel leurs employés et ils perdent
des possibles bénéfices qu'ils auraient
pu faire ces prochaines semaines alors
que l'été commence tout juste
selon le phare mais les discothèques ça
n'est pas une bonne solution puisque les
jeunes continuent à se réunir dans la
rue et ce sans les mesures sanitaires
qui sont pourtant demandé dans les
discothèques
je vous propose d'écouter ramon masse le
président du syndicat des discothèques
en catalogne il se ferme les boîtes de
barcelone en catalogne mais c'est pas
solutionné parce que la rue la pêche
les places seront pleines de gens en
train de voir en train de faire la fête
à la rue mais nous demandant une autre
chose nous voulons faire des dessins
antigènes et nous avons dit ça fait
longtemps qu'on pourrait faire un accord
avec les pharmacies les pharmacies non
pour faire le test lab a fermé les
discothèques ce n'est pas seulement un
problème pour le secteur du monde de la
nuit c'est aussi un problème pour toute
l'économie de barcelone l'ambiance de
fête de la ville en est et attire
beaucoup de touristes est également
beaucoup de français fermez les boîtes
de nuit c'est donc le prendre le risque
d'attirer moins de touristes même pour
quelques semaines
alors que barcelone en a cruellement
besoin pour renforcer son économie après
l'année blanche touristique qu'elle
vient de passer les restaurateurs les
hôteliers et les lieux culturels en ont
fortement besoin
les regards se tournent donc vers le
mois d'août est il possible de rattraper
les bénéfices qu'ils n'auront pas été
fait en juillet en seulement un mois
barcelone en tout cas garde l'espoir de
continuer à attirer des touristes dans
les prochaines semaines
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe emmanueli médecin libéral
exerçant dans la capitale catalane
bonsoir philippe even
d'être avec nous on l'a entendu le taux
d'incidence un qui a été multiplié par
huit en ces temps derniers jours en
catalogne ce qui a poussé donc le
gouvernement à fermer les discothèques
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
ces derniers développements est-ce qu'on
pouvait s'attendre à cette mauvaise
surprise
bonsoir stéphanie de nauru et bien oui
il y avait effectivement un risque
n'aurait assisté à une nouvelle phase
épidémique puisque d'une part
effectivement les les portes avaient été
largement réouverte plus d'un mois avant
la date qui avait été choisi l'année
dernière c'est à dire que mon art est
ouvert grand les portes fin mai alors
que l'année dernière on les avait
ouvertes sont joints et l'année dernière
et bien le rebond était arrivé deux mois
après c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer cette année le rebond
arrive deux mois après la réouverture
des portes de l'espagne et donc pour
cela ce n'est pas une surprise en cause
quoi philippe emmanueli les festivals
les rassemblements de jeunes qui ont
causé de nombreux kloster on aurait dû
les interdits on ne ne pas rouvrir tous
tous ces rassemblements
alors d'abord il faut pas comparer ce
qui est en train de se passer maintenant
avec ce qui s'est passé dans les
précédentes épidémies
c'est radicalement différent c'est
radicalement différent d'abord parce que
effectivement les populations à risque
aujourd'hui si on vacciner et donc les
populations qui se contaminent ce sont
les populations qui ne sont pas à risque
qui sont les jeunes et c'est vrai que ce
variant est très contagieux on le voit
très bien parce que le l'activité notre
activité a explosé et envoie 90% de
covile et ses 90 % de jeunes entre 20 et
30 ans en revanche il faut quand même
dire que ces jeunes présente très peu de
symptômes
donc oui
on a des cas qu'ovide positif mais ça ne
ressemble pas du tout sur le plan
clinique aux symptômes auquel on avait à
faire face aux précédentes aux
précédentes épidémies suivent leurs
précédentes aux précédents cycles
d'épidémie donc vraiment on est dans un
contexte complètement différent
1 et après il faut savoir que ce qui a
vraiment je dirais généré un retour à
des comportements à risque c'est la fin
du port du masque qui a été interprété
très clairement comme le retour total à
la vie normale si on vous suit vient
docteur on aller vacciner d'un côté
peut-être les jeunes de l'autre qui
développent des formes très peu gras va
vous suivre du coc vide
est ce que dans ces conditions ne
doit-on pas laisser tout simplement
faire marcher l'immunité collective et
surtout ne pas re confiné et ne pas
remettre des restrictions écoutez moi je
trouve qu'une certaine hypocrisie et une
certaine
comment dire superficialité du débat
scientifique parce que ce qu'on voit
également aujourd'hui ce sont des gens
qui sont vaccinés qui viennent faire
leur test pour reprendre l'avion et qui
sont positifs alors évidemment ils sont
pas malades
évidemment ils sont en quelque sorte
porter ça mais les vaccinés contribue
également à la diffusion du virus
simplement effectivement ils ne feront
jamais de formes graves et ils sont
protégés contre la maladie
donc c'est vrai qu'entre un jeune qui de
toute façon n'est pas à risque et
contribua à propager l'épidémie et un
vaccinés qui lui aussi ne sera pas
malade et mais contribue potentiellement
également à la diffusion de la maladie
on voit pas vraiment la différence et
c'est vrai que on n'insiste pas assez
sur cette question à mon avis en faisant
simplement la part des vaccinés et des
non vaccinés ça veut dire que ce débat
qu'on a aujourd'hui en france à
d'exhorter 1
la pression devient un petit peu lourde
d'exhorter les populations à se faire
vacciner compris les jeunes il est un
peu mince ce débat finalement selon vous
c'est normal que ce débat ait lieu mais
il faut que ce débat ait lieu dans des
conditions d'honnêteté scientifique et
comme médecin si vous voulez moi ce qui
me choque c'est que la première démarche
d'un médecin fasse si vous voulez au
discours d'un patient ou la prise de
position de quelqu'un c'est d'essayer de
comprendre et je pense qu'on devrait
s'interroger par exemple sur les raisons
qui poussent un pourcentage élevé des
professionnels de santé à ne pas
vacciner
il faudrait les interroger leur dire
pourquoi vous ne voulez pas vacciner au
lieu de ça e
finalement on tient un discours qui est
de dire les bons ce soir est vacciné les
méchants c'est ce qu'ils ne veulent pas
se vacciner mais on sait que la france a
connu un certain nombre de scandales
sanitaires
il ya eu du sang contaminé il ya une
médiator on sait donc que sur un certain
nombre de deux comment dire de mesures
sanitaires à grande échelle
il y a eu des accidents sanitaires et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'une partie de la
population des personnels de soins ont
en mémoire ces accidents sanitaires et
redoute alors que ce soient fondées ou
pas il faut en discuter mais là encore
il faut une honnêteté scientifiques
redoutent éventuellement la perspective
d'un nouvel accident sanitaires
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la veille de
l'été enfin déjà l'été d'ailleurs ça se
voit pas trop à paris dogon de mon
erreur vous craignez vous cet afflux
massif de touristes en espagne où vous
la voyez plutôt d'un dan hay
bienveillant nous ont pas écoutés je
pense que je pense que les jeux sont
faits c'est à dire que maintenant le
variant delta est en train de déferler
on retrouve exactement le même scénario
que l'année dernière donc les
contaminations vont se concentrer sur
l'espagne qui est vraiment un pays de
destination majeure de toute l'europe et
donc tout ça va faire émerger
vraisemblablement une vraie vague est
effectivement peut-être qu'on aura des
surprises au mois d'août puisque là
encore comme je vous le disais on a
réouvert grand les portes avec un mois
d'avancé sur l'année dernière merci
beaucoup philippa emmanueli d'avoir été
avec nous un médecin libéral exerçant
barcelone merci à vous le maroc en proie
de concevoir son propre vaccin en
partenariat avec le laboratoire
pharmaceutique signer forme objectifs du
royaume accéléré sa campagne de
vaccination et atteindre
l'autodétermination vaccinale les
précisions de notre correspondant au
maghreb bcm chebbi renforcer la
souveraineté sanitaire du maroc face aux
dépendance extérieure c'est l'objectif
que s'est fixé le royaume du maroc en
lançant la fabrication locale du vaccin
chinois sinopharm objectifs à court
terme une capacité de production de 5
millions de doses par mois
une coopération signés et apter entre le
royaume du maroc le groupe
pharmaceutique chinois lors d'une
cérémonie présidée par le roi mohamed 6
d'un montant global d'environ 2 421
millions d'euros selon l' agence de
presse marocaine
objectif pour les autorités sanitaires
accélérer l la campagne vaccinale débuté
au mois de janvier
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
yousra à bourabi maître de conférences à
sciences po rabat c'est une immunité qui
est qui est déjà en place et qui va
conduire continuer notamment avec ce
nouveau projet qui permettra notamment
d'assurer une certaine souveraineté en
matière de production et de moins
dépendre est bien de l'importation de
vaccins et pour ça c'est une très bonne
chose que la coopération commence dans
ce sens là c'est à dire que l'on puisse
déléguer la fabrication que l'on puisse
mettre en place des coopérations entre
pays pour la fabrication puisque c'est
une crise qui concerne absolument tous
les pays
avec plus de 10 millions de marocains
vacciner sur une population totale de 36
millions d'habitants le maroc malgré un
nombre d'infections à la hausse est l'un
des pays d'afrique et du maghreb où l'on
vaccine le plus
un bilan bien plus mitigée pour son
voisin tunisien qui connaît une
recrudescence importante des cas de
contamination tunis et peine toujours à
faire décoller sa campagne vaccinale est
temps d'accélérer ses partenariats en
vue d'acquérir plus de doses les
autorités viennent d'annoncer l'arrivée
sur le sol tunisien de 500 mille doses
de vaccin ainsi novak en provenance de
la république populaire de chine
l'inquiétude face aux variants delta
également en argentine le pays se
rapproche du cap des cent mille décès
duo kobe 19 une situation qui provoque
de nombreuses difficultés dans les
hôpitaux où le personnel est au bord de
l'épuisement cyrielle bruit
la lutte se poursuit dans les hôpitaux
argentin depuis plus de 15 mois médecins
et infirmières travaillent sans relâche
dans ce pays de 45 millions d'habitants
plus de quatre millions et demi de
personnes ont été infectées par le kobe
de 19
malgré une campagne de vaccination qui
s'est accéléré ces dernières semaines
les établissements de santé ne
désemplissent pas à l'hôpital san roque
et de cordoba le personnel soignant ne
cache plus son épuisement et
s'inquiètent des conséquences pour la
suite c'était vraiment choquant car cela
dépasser toutes formations que nous
aurions pu avoir quelques jours ou mois
avant de commencer la pandémie nous a
causé un épuisement physique
psychologique et de la tristesse car
nous avons perdu des collègues à cause
du comité un effort nous pensons
également que cela un fort impact sur le
système de santé en particulier sur le
personnel de santé qui est très fatigué
qui a dû supporter les deux vagues et
nous sommes convaincus qu'avec la
circulation du variant delta et certains
problèmes de circulation des personnes
nous aurons sûrement un troisième pic
d'hospitalisation
le nombre de patients dans les unités de
soins intensifs est sans précédent
nous n'avons jamais eu le nombre de
patients en soins intensifs sous
ventilation mécanique que nous avons
aujourd'hui alors que les hôpitaux sont
saturés certains secteurs comme le
tourisme connaissent d'autres types de
difficultés à buenos aires les hôtels
sont vidés de leur clientèle
avec 70 % des établissements de la
capitale fermée le secteur est considéré
comme le plus durement touchées du pays
la situation de l'industrie hôtelière en
argentine surtout à buenos aires est
désastreuse je crois qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres mots pour le dire
nous n'avons pas travaillé depuis 15
mois et des entreprises ont été
complètement fermée c'est pour le
tourisme international
donc tant que les frontières seront
fermés nous n'aurons pas de clients il
n'y a pas de client pour buenos aires
parce que ce n'était pas seulement ce
type de clients mais aussi beaucoup de
réunions d'entreprises
celle ci était purement corporatives et
un tourisme en argentine qui risquent de
peiner à redémarrer
le gouvernement argentin a décidé de
réduire les arrivées sur son sol
jusqu'au 31 août prochain seuls 600
personnes pourront rentrer
quotidiennement sur le territoire par
voie aérienne
un quota remis en question par les
députés de l'opposition qui ont présenté
un recours pour obtenir son annulation
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
selon l'algérie la france refuse de
dévoiler les lieux d'enfouissement des
déchets polluants radioactifs ou
chimiques n'ont découvert dans le sahara
puis nous parlerons du traité de la
charte sur l'énergie méconnu du grand
public ce traité international menace
grandement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution un
supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
prix puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement en l'état actuel des
capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terres rares il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes nous
bouleverse et nous bouleverse toujours
vous savez parce qu'on les comprend pas
il nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à haute valeur
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes prêts c'est
la même culture c'est la même façon de
penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir et
amine
[Musique]
et
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues avaient
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
font normalement les cellules sensibles
à la lumière dans la rétine pas ce qu'il
va dire qu'il voit un peu c'est il
distingue la lumière il distingue quoi
exactement par le patient et de lapins
par exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de grande taille plusieurs
niveaux en passe de les compter de les
attraper et comme c'est un patient qui
ne voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soit il est bienvenu en direct sur
arte france si vous nous rejoignez
nouveau coup dur dans les relations
entre la france et l'algérie l origine d
essai nucléaire mené par l'armée
française dans le sahara algérien
pendant les années 60
retour en images sur cette énième
contentieux
[Musique]
[Musique]
oh
il pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison question comment la france
va continuer à faire des essais même
après l'indépendance de l'algérie
tout simplement parce que c'était prévu
dans les accords d'evian conclu en mars
de 1 2962 et ces accords prévoyaient que
pendant au moins cinq années
la france pourrait continuer à faire des
essais dans le sahara alors pourquoi y
at il eu cette clause qui au départ
était d'ailleurs secrète
et bien tout simplement parce que ça
n'était pas une priorité pour le fln
puis pour le gouvernement algérien
d'arrêter ces essais à l'époque il n'y
avait d'ailleurs pas de réglementation
internationale il n'y avait pas traité
sur la non prolifération nucléaire
encore moins c'est venu beaucoup plus
tard de traité interdisant les essais et
puis on avait fait savoir à la
délégation qui négocie à evian que la
france avait fait quatre essais
atmosphériques entre 60 et 62 mais
qu'après l'indépendance elle se
cantonnerait à des essais souterrains et
qui sont évidemment moins en moins
polluants pour l'environnement et pour
les populations qui peuvent être au tour
alors cela dit les français ont remis
donc en 87 l'ensemble des lieux aux
autorités algériennes
après avoir démonté d'installation mais
et par conséquent boucher aussi les
galeries ou été fait les essais
souterrains mais ils ont laissé
probablement un certain nombre de
véhicules d'équipements militaires dont
ont testé la résistance au souffle de
l'explosion nucléaire et à certains de
chars de d'équipements militaires ont
été enterrés dans le sable et c'est ceci
qui aujourd'hui fait l'objet du
contentieux dont vous avez parlé à
l'instant dans votre sujet mais des
équipes de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie
deviennent sont venus au début des
années 2000 on examine la situation ont
établi un rapport
et puis en 2007 lors d'une visite de
monsieur sarkozy il a été convenu
d'établir un comité conjoint franco
algérien qui existent et qui pour le
moment n'a pas à donner beaucoup de
résultats donc ce problème reste entier
et il doit évidemment être traité il est
pourtant eu la loi morin a voté en 2010
pour indemniser les victimes des essais
nucléaires pourquoi n'at-elle pas
bénéficier aux algériens et alors la loi
morin qui a été adoptée en 2010 a été
amendée à s'attendre deux fois et fait
l'objet de beaucoup de récriminations
d'abord des organisations de victimes
françaises
parce que elle a institué un comité qui
est assez bureaucratique dans son
fonctionnement et qui semble-t-il n'a
jusqu'à présent admis qu'une douzaine de
dossiers éligibles sur environ 900 qu'on
lui a présenté alors ça c'est pour les
ressortissants français
évidemment c'est encore plus difficile
pour les ressortissants algériens qui
historiquement sont éligibles
mais comme on le dit dans le vocabulaire
fleuri de l'administration française
on qualifie les algériens qui habitait
dans ces zones de travailleurs des oasis
alors puisqu'ils étaient travailleurs
des oasis il n'avait pas réellement de
domicile et ils peuvent difficilement
prouvé qu'il était dans ces villages à
proximité des essais au moment où les
essais en lieu c'est trop compliqué pour
eux et par conséquent les dossiers
n'arrive pas ne parviennent pas à ce
comité qui par ailleurs est sans doute
beaucoup trop sélectif donc il faut
probablement modifier la loi morin ce
sujet est à peine évoqué par le rapport
stora qui est relativement discret sur
le sujet des essais nucléaires dans le
sahara alors cette nouvelle crise franco
algérienne je dirais même cette énième
crise ce qu'elles ne risquent pas de
mettre à mal tous les efforts de
repentance qu'ont entrepris emmanuel
macron
alors repentance et un vocabulaire un
peu un peu religieux qui vient peut-être
d'ailleurs de l'inquisition ne s'agit
pas du tout de problème religieux
il s'agit de problèmes de relations
internationales et le problème concret
est ce que monsieur t bounadi dans les
différentes interviews qu'il a données
ces derniers jours et notamment une
grande interview à une chaîne de
télévision dimanche dernier ceux qui
avaient des problèmes concrets
et puis il ya des problèmes de mémoire
alors pour ce qui est des problèmes de
mémoire
il faut appeler les choses par leur nom
il n'y a pas d'évènement d'algérie il ya
eu une guerre d'indépendance
il n'y a pas eu des événements à sétif
en 45 il ya eu des émeutes à sétif qui
ont fait un certain nombre de morts il
faut nommer les choses et ouvrir les
dossiers et écrire l'histoire comme elle
s'est déroulée
et puis les brumes concret celui du
sahara et de la contamination de
certaines populations en état il y en a
d'autres par exemple accès aux archives
pourquoi est ce que les chercheurs
français n'ont pas accès aux archives
algériennes
pourquoi est ce que les chercheurs
algériens n'ont pas accès aux archives
françaises
c'est aussi un autre problème concret
qui devra être résolue dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines ou dans les prochains mois
monsieur teboul s'est montré
relativement optimiste sur l'évolution
des relations entre la france et
l'algérie est dans le fond a eu des
paroles plutôt aimable pour le président
de la république française en disant
qu'il comprenait bien la situation qu'il
avait d'ailleurs déjà fait beaucoup de
pas en direction de l'algérie qu'il
avait reconnu qu' à l'époque de la
colonisation des crimes avaient été
commis et que par conséquent il était
dans l' dans l'acte dans une optique de
compréhension de la position algérienne
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il fallait
s'excuser pour une situation qui date
d'il ya maintenant beaucoup d'années
vous l'avait dit et pour des
comportements de
c'est grand père donc on en est là et
cela dira le ministre des moudjahidine
donc les anciens combattants a réclamé
comme vous l'avez dit aussi dans votre
sujet que le terrain genre français
donnent les cartes d'enfouissement des
matériels qui ont été contaminés par ces
explosions et qui étaient là comme
témoin de la résistance des matériaux et
en effet je pense que ceci sera
probablement fait dans la période qui
vient
monsieur tebboune a aussi été jusqu'à
évoquer dans cette interview télévisée
l'hypothèse d'un échange de visites
présidentielles entre la france et
l'algérie
dès que la situation la situation du
coup vite 19 permettra que cet échange à
très haut niveau puisse avoir lieu
donc il est aux pubs il est plutôt dans
une optique de réconciliation et dans le
fond suivant en cela l'exemple d'autres
pays comme le vietnam et ont jamais
demandé d' excuses et qui on tourne
depuis pas mal d'années des rapports
excellents avec la france merci beaucoup
claudin blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
un sixième cycle de discussions s'est
ouvert hier pour faire évoluer un traité
favorable aux compagnies énergétiques de
53 pays ce traité sur la charte de
l'énergie permettant aux entreprises du
pétrole du charbon ou le gaz d'attaqué
des pays qui menace leurs intérêts et l
on travaille ainsi le combat crucial
contre le réchauffement climatique
les explications de katia pique nique
des informations du prochain rapport du
giec et qui détaille l'impact du
réchauffement climatique ont fuité
elle conclut que la hausse des
températures de 1 5° seulement pourrait
entraîner des conséquences graves
pendant des siècles et parfois
irréversibles inondations famines le
verdict est terrifiant apocalyptique les
énergies fossiles sont responsables de
70 % des émissions de co2 les pays du
monde entier doivent en conséquence
mener des politiques drastiques pour
limiter leur exploitation mais ce n'est
pas possible parce qu'ils ont traité le
traité sur la charte de l'énergie dit et
c'est eux donnent des pouvoirs a
considéré aux compagnies énergétiques
ce traité a été signé en 1994 par 53
pays dont les pays européens
le kazakhstan le tadjikistan le japon
son objectif était de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement en énergie fossile
des pays d'europe à partir des anciennes
nations du bloc soviétique
le tc a prévu une protection des
investissements des compagnies
énergétiques
mais aujourd'hui les objectifs de la
transition écologique vont diminuer ses
profits or en vertu de ce traité un
investisseur étranger peut poursuivre
les états qui menacent et intérêts
devant un tribunal privé bien plus
favorable aux compagnies que les
tribunaux nationaux se traitait méconnu
et 10 écocide obsolète par ses
détracteurs il est une entrave à la
transition écologique pour deux raisons
primo les compagnies exploitant des
énergies fossiles exige des milliards de
compensation
le tc eux a jusqu'ici permis de traiter
135 plainte avec des additions de
millions ou centaines de millions réglée
par les états selon l'analyste des
politiques énergétiques yamina saheb
le coût de ces plaintes pourraient
s'élever à plus de 1000 milliards en
2050 dont 42 pour cent seraient payés
par les contribuables
secundo ces compagnies peuvent influer
sur l'élaboration des législations
nationales qui deviennent anti environ
mentale en france en 2010 est nicolas
hulot préparer une loi pour interdire
l'exploitation et l'exploration
d'hydrocarbures d'ici 2040
l'une des principales entreprises
exploitant des concessions
d'hydrocarbures en france le canadien
vermillon avait alors écrit au conseil
d'état la lettre de ses avocats a évoqué
ce projet de loi ces attentes légitimes
faisant planer la menace d'un procès le
conseil d'état a alors conseillé de
continuer à protéger les opérateurs
miniers
nicolas hulot a dû plier et reculer
alors que faire modifier le traité un
sixième cycle de discussions se tient du
6 au 9 juillet pour le faire évoluer la
commission européenne venait de proposer
un projet de révision qui a été d'emblée
rejeté par les autres signataires la
ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili set emporté devant
l'assemblée nationale le 22 juin dernier
le processus de modernisation du traité
qui est engagée de en 2020 ne semble
pour être très clair pas être en bonne
voie
tous les états ne semble malheureusement
pas partager les ambitions européennes
en matière climatique c'est pourquoi
nous envisageons de proposer un retrait
coordonné de l'union européenne et de
ses états membres est il imaginable de
quitter l'accord comme l'italien en 2016
une clause crépusculaire qui porte bien
son nom prévoit que les compagnies
pourront toujours attaquer l'état
sortant durant 20 ans c'est pourquoi à
l'instar de barbara pompidou plus de 300
députés européens et nationaux ont
enjoint les états de l'union à faire une
sortie coordonnées de l'accord avec un
pacte de non agression
plus de 400 ong ont plaidé pour cette
sortie des signataires d'ici la réunion
de la coop 26 en novembre 2000 21
glasgow mais pour le moment une poignée
de compagnies énergétiques continuent à
avoir gain de cause et à faire monter la
température
et pour en parler nous sommes avec guy
benarroch sénateur europe ecologie les
verts des bouches du rhône bonsoir guy
benarroch merci
direct sur rt france sortir de ce traité
pour l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne c'est selon vous la seule
solution pour entamer une véritable
transition écologique
oui bonsoir effectivement en tout cas la
position et la vie a été rappelée
s'agissait pour nous et pour le groupe
de tous les eurodéputés verts d'ailleurs
de renégocier le traité
peut-elle s'asseoir us est compatible
avec les objectifs sont de plus en plus
fixés par les pays européens qui traduit
visuellement aussi par l'europe en
particulier par exemple dans la nouvelle
loi climat que je n'approuve pas
totalement mais en tout cas
l'article est cette nouvelle voie climat
dit qu'il faut rentrer dans les clous
des objectifs fixés par l'europe par
mois 55 % d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et donc pour arriver à ces
résultats on peut pas en euros n'est
obligé l'europe et obliger chacun de ces
pays de renégocier l'accord de sauvetage
négocié ce traité ou d'en sortir
il ya d'autres solutions offertes
comment vous expliquez guy benarroch
qu'on laisse autant de liberté aux
investisseurs et ses entreprises des
énergies fossiles
on est dans une société ça vous a pas
échappé qui est une société libérale sur
les règles de cette cité du gant les
connais bien et en particulier celle du
libre marché qui est ce assez régulé par
sa main invisible la totalité des
transactions et donc où les traités
européens depuis des années sans des
traités européens qui répondent une
idéologie est connoté l'économie
libérale et qui dort dans ce sens-là
d'aucuns comparent très bien que quand
il a été négocié initialement ce traité
ça montre quand même à bêtises mais je
pense que ça n'a de 1994 donc lorsqu'il
a été ratifiée le contexte était
fondamentalement différent de ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
il m'a bien bien que les problèmes et
les problématiques écologiques et de
laideur fsr était déjà présente en tout
cas elle n'était pas opérationnel
au niveau européen ni au niveau des
différents traités qui avait pu être
signé aujourd'hui il en est différemment
tout nu à la conscience parce que les
événements et les différentes études
scientifiques ont prouvé que c'était une
nécessité aujourd'hui de réguler le
marché en fonction des exigences de
finitude de notre planète tout le monde
a conscience aujourd'hui qu'il faut
changer mais les traités glisse toujours
deux sociétés dans l'économie libérale
capitaliste d'un intérêt financier ce
que le traité persiste un stylet et donc
on a affaire à une lutte qui est une
lutte permanente entre des intérêts
privés capitalistique de profits qui
sont tout à fait légitimes dans une
société capitaliste et et la réalité de
ce qui est nécessaire aujourd'hui pour
faire subsister l'humanité sur terre or
c'est un traité sauf erreur de ma part
qui est plutôt méconnu en europe en tout
cas il n'est pas très médiatisé on en
parle assez peu pour quelles raisons
selon vous il est tout à fait méconnu
vous avez parfaitement raison
d'ailleurs il le serait plus nous
n'étions pas aujourd'hui d'abord être
revenu au niveau du parlement européen
s'il n'y avait pas ça très nombreux
l'association je pense vous l'avez dit
notre très grand nombre
pas seulement hausse qui s'étaient
manifestés à ce sujet beaucoup de
traités commerciaux ou de traiter de ce
type là aujourd'hui
somme toute assez méconnu il parce que
parce que je n'étais ce ne sont pas des
traités qui ont encore donné lieu à
certains nombres de la formation
publicité il comment dire il faisait
partie au fait du business as usual qui
était pratiqué par l'europe jusqu'à
présent cc je suis pas étonné qu'il soit
resté méconnu jusqu'à présent voilà ce
qu'ils veulent ce qui m'importe est là
c'est qu'il ya une renégociation
qu'apparemment il ya quand même un
accord le grand nombre de pays européens
pour négocier que cette négociation ne
semble pas possible puisque les éléments
de ce traité on laisse quand même un
levier 1 bat force important
aux compagnies privées qui l'a négocié à
l'époque avec les héros pays y compris
les pays européens mais par contre les
choses auront évolué donc aujourd'hui la
seule face à semble-t-il de de pouvoir
continuer à poursuivre ses objectifs
mais ceux qui sont fixées par les états
et par leur politique
malgré ce genre de traiter une
conversion de libre change parce qu'on
va l'appeler comme ça ton état parmi
d'autres nous faut qu' il va falloir
sortir de ce traité pour pouvoir ne pas
être sujets à des risques de d'attac
judiciaire et donc des pénalités à payer
alors justement un quatrième cycle de
négociations ralliant en 2021 encore ce
il se tient actuellement pour faire
changer les choses mais il faut pour
cela l'unanimité des 53 est-ce qu'on
peut quand même cette fois ci espérait
que ça bouge quelque reserrement ces
traités sur fait de telle façon que
l'unanimité des 53 paraît toujours plus
compliqué elle est soumise à des aléas
des aléas des intérêts de chacun des
pays je parle pas des terrains plats
chauds d'almeida terré ne serait-ce que
l'économique de chacun des pays la
conscience ou l'importance de la lutte
contre le changement climatique n'est
pas n'est pas le même n'est pas la même
dans chacun de ces pays est donc super
d'avoir pour certains des intérêts
économiques y sont toujours placés au
dessus de la transition écologique ou de
la transition énergétique donc s'assurer
aujourd'hui que les 53 pays puissent
décider de renégocier l'accord paraît
très compliqué et pour ça que je dis au
final que je ne vois guère d'autres
solutions un moment donné que d'essayer
de se sortir de ce traité là dans la
mesure où ce sera possible
et de sortir au niveau de tous les pays
qui souhaiteront voilà parce que
l'europe elle est engagée par la
signature des 53 pays
di menna roche vous je vous invite
pardon à rester avec nous puisque on va
parler
d'un autre sujet qui rejoint celui ci
puisque la responsabilité des banques 1
face au défi climatique c'est l'objet
d'un appel de plus d'une centaine de
sociétés d'investissement afin que ces
banques
en face justement davantage pour le
climat la proche de la coop 26
l'objectif est de stopper le financement
des entreprises qui compterait encore
sur le charmant dans leur production est
la réponse des grandes banques est
attendue d'ici le 15 août avant
d'envisager d'éventuelles sanctions lors
de différentes assemblées d'actionnaires
et nous vous retrouvons donc à guy
benarroch là on comprend que contrario
une centaine de sociétés
d'investissement ont lancé un appel aux
banques comme par exemple jp morgan ou
les deux banques pour qu'elles fassent
davantage pour pour le climat s'est
clairement pour vous une lueur d'espoir
s'attaquer au levier financier c'est le
meilleur moyen finalement de faire
bouger les choses
tout à fait nous avons essayé à présent
certain nombre de propositions dans le
cadre de la loi climat qui vient d'être
voté au sénat
nous avons essayé de d'inclure dans la
loi grenelle ii concrètes et de deux
possibilités justement légal de
d'orienter les investissements des
banques ou leurs goûts leurs traits ou
leur couleur ou leur facilité de crédit
de les orienter 10 m à sa part de
critères on se disait justement aux
particuliers les entreprises qui y sont
encore dans l'économie des énergies
fossiles
nous avons essayé en vain c'est à dire
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de travail à
sion puisque nous n'avons pas réussi à
faire passer ces six amendements qui
n'était pas dans la loi présenté par le
gouvernement et qui ont été rejetées par
la majorité de droite du sénat
toujours pour la raison majeure qui est
celle de la libre entreprise
on a donc mais c'est un secteur pro bahn
est compliqué mais effectivement le fait
que ces trésors de société
d'investissement puisse elle-même fixer
des règles ou fixer des normes ou fixer
des quotas ruban dans le même état
d'esprit on aura vraisemblablement
autant de poids si ce n'est plus que la
chance nous avons pu avoir au sénat
il faudra accompagner sa au niveau
logistique c'est une obligation c'est
une certitude
vous avez le sentiment guy ménard auch
qu'aujourd'hui les sociétés privées
quand elles décident d'agir civiquement
est ce qu'elles font peut-être parfois
plus que certains états non c'était
privé dont 30 en deux ans dans le
système économique dans lequel nous
vivons est une société qui est destiné à
faire des profits et on peut pas lui
reprocher discus et des signes
l'organisation de l'économie du modèle
économique note qui fait qu utile donc
en titre s'est tenue aujourd'hui décide
de certains nombres de deux d'actions y
compris dans le sens de ce qui ne doit
souhaiter au niveau de la transition
écologique la sauvegarde du climat de la
préservation de la biodiversité et parce
qu'elles y trouvent un intérêt
économique donc dans certains cas
l'intérêt économique de ces sociétés
rejoint effectivement nous nous demander
ce que nous souhaitons et donc nous nous
retrouvons alliés de faim avec ces
sociétés on peut pas refuser cette
alliance sous prétexte à des sociétés
privées donc elles vont contribuer aussi
au changement de modèle et à la
préservation du à la fois du cna et de
et de la biosphère et de la biodiversité
jean forcément dans ce cas le poids qui
peut être par moments au niveau on va
dire internationale au niveau mondial
qui peut être plus important que celui
de parlement d'arménie quel couple
merci beaucoup en tout cas guy benarroch
sénateur europe ecologie les verts des
bouches du rhône d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france et c'est la fin
de cette émission prochain point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée avec
emilie google ce soit
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans